A visualization of our Standford racing car, Junior,
in action, applying that exact same algorithm for actual driving.
You can see here that a right turn is being executed, followed by a lane shift.
These are discrete actions, and the car actually performs those
to reach a goal location at the orange circle.
But if we make a lane shift prohibitively expensive,
just as we made a left turn expensive before,
then the car chooses a different path.
It goes straight, then takes a left turn, which right now isn't that expensive.
It takes a left turn and a left turn again to find itself
in the lane where the goal location is located.
That is a result of modifying cost functions in our dynamic programming algorithm
in the same 3D regime we just studied and that you just programmed.
Your program could effectively drive this car, and by changing these cost function,
as you can see over here, the car would be able to attain its goal
in the optimal way, relative to the cost that you have given him.
Congratulations. You made it through my first motion class.
Today we assumed that the world is discrete,
and we looked at 2 planning algorithms--A-star, which uses a heuristic to find a path,
and dynamic programming, which finds an entire policy that has a plan for every location.
We implemented both of them.
In fact, in the policy case, even in 3D, which is quite an achievement.
I want to congratulate you to get here.
You really now understand two of the main paradigms
by which our robots make motion decisions,
and they are are also some very major paradigms for artificial intelligence in general.
In the next class we talk about how to turn this into actual robot motion.
We'll talk about continuous state spaces, and we'll talk about what's called "control,"
in which we make a robot move. I'll see you next week.